We live our lives through our phones.
They're now our screens of choice to enjoy everything...
...from TV shows to mind-blowing games.
But smartphones still look the same as they did a decade ago:...
...buttons, bezels and frames,...
...that all get in our way...
...until now.
Unbox your phone.
Samsung Galaxy S8.
The new Infinity Display gives you an incredible fullscreen experience,...
...yet fits comfortably in your hand.
We created it by reorganizing the phone's interior,...
...making components smaller without sacrificing performance...
...and embedding the home button under the screen.
We created the beautifully-curved edge display...
...and also erased the bezels to give you more space for the things that matter.
The Galaxy S8 will take you beyond the limits of any phone...
...you've ever known before.
Unbox your phone.
Samsung Galaxy S8 and S8+.